wirklich alle energieprobleme unserer
welt könnten mit rentablen kern
fusionsreaktoren auf einen schlag gelöst
werden denn bei dieser technik die ja
nach dem großen vorbild der sonne
funktioniert entsteht eben nicht
tonnenweise klimaschädliches co2
bisher haben sich forschungsteams
weltweit auf riesige große und komplexe
reaktoren wie inter in frankreich und
wendelstein 7-x bei kreisweiten
konzentriert doch jetzt ist fachleuten
eine kernfusion in einem objekt gelungen
das so klein ist dass man es zu hause
aufbewahren könnte klingt zum science
fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes eines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nichts
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
der große traum vieler forschungsteams
eine kernfusion die umweltverträglich
sauberen strom produziert und damit den
immer weiter steigenden energiebedarf
der erde decken könnte das soll
beispielsweise mit dem größten
fusionsreaktor der welt im süden von
frankreich auf den weg gebracht werden
hinter das steht für international
thermonukleare experimente reaktor im
jahr 2025 soll dort das erste plasma
gezündet werden nach weiteren
installationen ist das eigentliche ziel
für 2035 angepeilt der betrieb mit
deuterium und tritium die zu einem
neutron und einem helium kernfusion
ehren aber auch in deutschland ist man
mit dem kern soll sie uns experiment
wendelstein 7-x bei greifswald vorne mit
dabei
wir haben immer mal wieder darüber
berichtet hier sollen nach einem umbau
fusions relevanten plasmen mit einer
heizleistung von acht megawatt erzeugt
werden tatsächlich doppelt so viel wie
bisher das plasma wird dabei
unvorstellbaren 70 millionen grad
celsius heiß und soll nach den
vorstellungen des kreiswahl der
forschungsteams zehn sekunden lang
stabil bleiben und das ist gar nicht so
unrealistisch denn experten und
expertinnen halten die kernfusion anlage
für eine der modernsten
forschungsanlagen überhaupt alle diese
projekte haben eines gemeinsam sie haben
das ziel die kräfte der sonne auch auf
der erde zu entfesseln
denn natürliche kernfunktionen gibt es
eben nur in sternen in unserer sonne und
zwar verschmelzen dabei atomkerne durch
die extrem hohen temperaturen und den
enormen druck im inneren
zu einem neuen kern band steht helium
und eine riesige menge an energie wird
freigesetzt deswegen wird die kernzone
auch als die neue prämie energiequelle
gehandelt und könnte tatsächlich co2
frei erneuerbare energien ergänzen und
das ist dabei vor allem viel
ungefährlicher als die aktuelle atom
spaltung in kernkraftwerken hier kann es
zu einer super gefährlichen
kettenreaktionen kommen die unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung freisetzt weiß
reaktor kommt die reaktion bei einem
unfall dagegen direkt zum erliegen und
die radioaktiven stoffe die entstehen
besitzen eine halbwertzeit von
jahrzehnten und nicht von millionen so
auch eine studie des max planck
instituts für plasmaphysik dass das
problem mit dem anfallenden radioaktiven
müll als händelbar eingestuft hat die
konfusion wäre also ein
riesenfortschritt und so dient der
betrieb solch großer kern
fusionsreaktoren als vorarbeit für den
bau eines kraftwerks das den besten fall
schon in naher zukunft erste
elektrizität und dann auch kommerziell
nutzbare fusionsenergie erstellt das
ziel des britischen unternehmens
zuckermarkt energy möchte beispielsweise
mit seinen reaktor namen stalker marquez
t40 bereits im jahr 2025 erste
elektrizität herstellen bis 2030 soll
dann auch kommerziell nutzbares energie
produziert werden dabei konzentriert
sich die fachwelt fast ausschließlich
eben auf große und komplexe reaktoren
die sich über mehrere meter erstrecken
sie sind ausgestattet mit externen
magnetfeldern und komplexer elektronik
die die kontrolle über das basler
möglich machen ein forschungsteam von
der universität washington hat jetzt
einen anderen weg eingeschlagen die
experten und expertinnen haben in einer
vergleichsweise klein apparatur den
vorgang der kernfusion möglich gemacht
der so genannte set ist so klein dass er
auf einem gewöhnlichen esstisch platz
findet das plasma und in diesem
versuchsaufbau eingeklemmt also
komprimiert dieser sogenannte schutzlos
sorgt dafür dass das plasma stabilisiert
wird zu diesem zweck wird die
spezifische orientierung das passende
eigenen magnetfeldes genutzt quasi wie
eine art zylinder der in der mitte
gestaucht wird
in einem flaschenhals zwängt sich das
heiße plasma durch diese stelle in durch
dieser versuchsaufbau für
fusionsreaktoren ist alles andere als
neu doch er geriet in vergessenheit da
sich als instabil herausstellte und das
plasma in die saiten bis zu hin dass
kräfte doch das forschungsteam aus
washington konnte dieses problem lösen
das gelang in dem die experten und
expertinnen aus wasserstoff und
deuterium ein stabiles platz mehr
erzeugten und zwar im verhältnis 80 zu
ein erfolg denn das so erzeugte plasma
blieb 5 mikrosekunden stabil um es
einmal deutlich zu machen eine million
mikrosekunden entspricht einer sekunde
auch wenn das natürlich erst einmal nach
einer äußerst kurzen zeitspanne klingt
war es tatsächlich lange genug um eine
kernfusion zu erreichen im vergleich zur
vorherigen versuchen in diesem
zusammenhang war das passt man sogar
5000 mal stabiler also wirklich ein im
wahrsten sinne des wortes kleiner
fortschritt in sachen kernfusionstechnik
aber er könnte große folgen haben wie
funktioniert kernfusion
also wenn ihr etwas erfahren wollt nach
diesem video anklicken und anschauen bei
doktor watson und dann natürlich
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran